un bon soir jeudi 15 octobre bienvenue
dans cette édition spéciale proposée par
la rédaction de tv 78 une émission
largement consacrée à la mise en oeuvre
du couvre-feu dans les yvelines à partir
de samedi 17 octobre et pour quatre
semaines minimum le couvre-feu est donc
décrété dans les yvelines et le reste de
l'ile-de-france tout comme pour huit
métropoles françaises annonce hier des
manuels macron pour endiguer la deuxième
vague de kobe de 19
un couvre-feu qui sera effective de 21h
à 6h du matin explications à suivre lé
réaction également des habitants élus et
professionnels yvelinois du monde de la
restauration et de la culture la députée
marie le bec sera aussi avec nous enfin
quel impact pour le sport amateur c'est
au menu de cette édition spéciale
et puis enfin des éditions nous
parlerons également d'un autre sujet non
moins important celui du don du sang
avec des réserves qui sont au plus bas
depuis 10 ans nous recevons le docteur
ahmed slimani de l'établissement
français d'île de france
cet objectif de manière très concrète
c'est freiner le virus c'est faire que
ces vingt mille nouveaux cas par jour
on va devoir les ramener à 3 5000 cas
par jour parce que là on peut maîtriser
c'est que ces 200 entrées en réanimation
on doit aussi fortement les réduire pour
au fond revenir à un niveau de nombre de
cas qu vide en réanimation qui est de
l'ordre de 10 à 15% d'honorer à au
maximum et donc la décision que nous
avons prise
c'est en effet un couvre-feu un
couvre-feu qui va s'appliquer à la
région ile de france où le virus circule
très activement
il débutera donc ce samedi 17 17 octobre
à minuit dans la nuit de vendredi à
samedi donc le couvre-feu sera effectif
dans toute l'île de france est donc dans
les yvelines pour une durée de quatre
semaines qui peut être allongée à six
semaines un couvre-feu de 21h à 6h du
matin qu'en pensent les yvelinois
regarder ses propos recueillis par
eléonore sinoquet mélanie poker trouve
ça inutile guidyu enfin comme en direct
de toute façon ça sert à rien je trouve
que de toute façon les gens se réuniront
quand même chez eux
la fête se fera ailleurs ça ne pose
aucun problème d'abord parce que je suis
pas donc ça c'est une première raison
est ensuite il faut bien lutter contre
le virus donc ça me paraît tout à fait
raisonnable franchement je trouve ça un
peu ridicule parce que pour moi il
aurait fallu s'y prendre largement avant
clairement donc bon après on n'a pas
trop le choix de faire rentrer plus tôt
mais au niveau clientèle au niveau
commercial c'est pas une bonne idée
je suis pour pour la vie de famille je
suis content parce que d'un point de vue
professionnel c'est handicapant non pas
voilà comme nous on a moins de de
contamination que les autres que
d'autres départements d'ile-de-france et
du coup bah on aurait pu nous être un
peu je peux plus léger sur moi j'appelle
ça une sanction
voilà pour ces réactions parmi la
population reste avec nous dans un
instant on vous explique tout en
compagnie de la rédaction de tv 78
présente sur ce plateau une réaction
d'abord politique à vous proposer celle
de valérie pécresse la présidente de la
région ile de france qui était l'invité
ce matin de nos confrères d'rtl
le couvre-feu était le seul choix
possible selon elle pour endiguer
l'épidémie l'écouté la situation des
hôpitaux dans les grandes métropoles et
en ile de france est très alarmante
et face à cette situation nous n'avons
pas d'autre choix que de nous résoudre
au couvre-feu
nous n'avons pas d'autre choix ça va
être une épreuve qu'on va devoir
traverser ensemble mais nous devons nous
retrousser les manches parce qu'il faut
sauver des vies et sauver l'activité
économique
le couvre-feu est aujourd'hui la seule
réponse crédible à cette situation qui
est une situation assez dramatique et
dans un instant marie lebey qui est
également député des yvelines sera avec
nous en plateau mais d'abord j'accueille
tout de suite sur ce plateau patrice
carmouze bonsoir bonsoir directeur de
l'information de tv 78 et mélanie poké
bonsoir de la rédaction télé 78,2 me
tourne d'ailleurs vers vous pour
commencer à partir de minuit samedi les
habitants de la région ile de france
vont devoir respecter un couvre-feu et
oui vous l'avez dit gregory pour quatre
semaines maximum il devra être respecté
de 21h à 6h à 21h attention c'est
l'heure où il faudra être chez soi en
cas de non respect vous risquez une
amende de 135 euros
le président souhaite que le couvre-feu
dure jusqu'à six semaines mais pour
qu'il soit prolongé
il lui faudra un accord du parlement il
y aura cependant des
exception pour se rendre ou rentrer du
travail aussi en cas d'urgence des
dérogations sont possibles pour des
raisons de santé comme l'achat de
médicaments dans une pharmacie de garde
ou pour aller à l'hôpital pour des
raisons professionnelles si vous aurez
vous empêche d'être chez vous à 21h pour
un voyage en train ou en avion avec
billets à l'appui pour vous rendre
auprès d'un proche dépendant ou pour
sortir votre animal de compagnie il y
aura une attestation à remplir comme
lors du confinement une attestation qui
se trouvera sur les sites du
gouvernement et du ministère de
l'intérieur
elle sera effective pendant une heure or
déplacements professionnels et pourra
être manuscript voilà qu'on se couvre
feu mais ce n'étaient pas les seules
annonces hier du président de la
république s'il n'ya pas de cadre
vraiment légal
le président a fait appel au civisme et
à la responsabilité de tous avec la
règle des six à respecter même dans le
cadre privé lors d'un dîner entre amis
d'un anniversaire ou au restaurant
il ne faudra pas être plus de 6 pour ce
qui est des fêtes les mariages ou les
anniversaires qui devait se faire dans
des lieux publics type salle des fêtes
ces rassemblements sont interdits
le port du masque est aussi recommandé
par tous là aussi dans la sphère privée
le télétravail est recommandé autant que
possible et ce sont des mesures qui vont
aussi avoir un impact économique et
social tout à l'heure le gouvernement a
annoncé d'ailleurs qu'il allait
continuer à soutenir les secteurs les
plus impactés aussi les personnes les
plus fragiles et oui le fonds de
solidarité est très large il sera ouvert
aux entreprises de tous les secteurs
dans les zones de couvre feu toutes les
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés en
zone de couvre-feu qui ont perdu 50 % de
leur chiffre d'affaires par rapport à
2019 pourront bénéficier d'une aide
allant jusqu'à 1500 euros
pendant toute la durée du couvre-feu
toujours les entreprises de moins de 50
salariés mais du monde de l'hôtellerie
de la restauration de la culture ou
encore du sport en cas de baisse de 50%
du chiffre d'affaires une aide pour
aller jusqu'à dix mille euros par mois
en ce qui concerne les prêts garantis
par l'état une demande de report d'un an
supplémentaire auprès de la fédération
française fédération bancaire française
a été faite par le ministre de
l'économie
ils seront ainsi accessibles jusqu'au 30
juin 2021 et une aide exceptionnelle
sera versée aux bénéficiaires du rsa et
des apl cela représente 150 euros
minimum par bénéficiaire et 100 euros
par enfant
toutes les mesures annoncées par le
président et par le gouvernement seront
adaptés et précisé
samedi après différentes concertations
merci mélanie pour toutes ces précisions
patrice carmouze d'hier le président de
la république a donc annoncé ce
couvre-feu le terme de couvre-feu est
lui-même intéressant bah oui ça va
tarder du local gérard guerrier alors
c'est pas très étonnant qu'on vous
souvenez quand il l'avait annoncé le
confinement et david hinde sommes en
guerre nous sommes en guerre donc en
quantité dans ce registre là alors c'est
historiquement haut pour appeler basket
amusant cet instinct mocky qui vient de
guillaume le coquin en étant 1060 alors
il y avait des incendies qui se
propagent est un peu partout et donc les
habitants devaient couvrir le feu à vis
de ça vient de là et puis après c'est
devenu guerrier vous pendant
l'occupation par exemple il est interdit
de sortir pendant l'occupation allemande
interdit de sortir le soir c'était le
couvre-feu alors vocabulaire guerrier
mais au fond pourquoi valérie pécresse
le disait parce que c'est une course
poursuite avec le virus et d'idc d'aller
plus vite que le virus était fière de
faire en sorte que les hôpitaux ne soit
pas surcharger c'est ça la grande
crainte aux fossés michel offrait une
phrase qui résume assez bien des
musiciens d'oeuvre simpliste il dit
comme l'hôpital est incapable de
fonctionner bas on nous dit de rester
chez nous c'est un peu ça quand même
la question qu'on peut se poser c'est
est ce que les français vont respecter
ce couvre-feu
alors c'est la vraie mesure parce que ça
concède quand même 20 millions de
personnes dans la france entière
et puis avec des territoires c'est
dissemblables regarder dans les yvelines
est ce que ça va être respecté de la
même façon versailles à trappes
on sait pas et puis pendant le
confinement les gens étaient assez aux
bisons ça s'est plutôt bien passé là on
commence à entendre des gens des
restaurateurs qui dit mais moi je m'en
fous je vais je continue à ouvrir - sort
en tant pis si à des sanctions
donc on va voir ça va être obligée
civile désobéissance civile ça va être
le vrai problème est la deuxième
question comment le faire respecter
alors ça les maires commencent à dire on
sait très bien c'est à nous de faire
respecter le couvre-feu seulement on n'a
pas forcément les forces de police pour
le faire alors si les gens s'aperçoivent
que après tout ils peuvent sortir à 21h
n'y a pas de sanctions ça va aussi
s'imposer un problème dernière question
est ce qu'à votre avis emmanuel macron
prend de gros risques avec cette
nouvelle mesure le couvre-feu a une fois
de plus il est seul quoi il est sale et
laid en première ligne il a été seul
dans les
la sphère des gilet jaune il était seul
dans le confinement à ses seuls dans le
confinement
j'ai de prendre lui-même les décisions
mais après tout je crois qu'il a intégré
l'idée que si propre à de risque bah il
sera pas réélu pour être réécrit une
deuxième fois il faut vraiment prendre
des risques merci patrice pour cet
éclairage dans un instant les réactions
politiques à rester avec nous je vous
disais tout à l'heure marie le bec
député des yvelines sera avec nous mais
d'abord ce reportage il avait échappé
aux mesures il avait échappé aux mesures
prises au mois de septembre les
restaurateurs yvelinois vont cette fois
ci être largement touchée par cette
mesure du couvre-feu l'inquiétude est de
mise regarder ce sujet d'astrid bergère
et de patrick jacques de dixmude coup
dur pour les restaurateurs qui était
déjà en difficulté
il sera interdit de circuler après 21h
dans les yvelines à partir de samedi au
lendemain des annonces de nombreuses
interrogations occupe les esprits
ça va être compliqué moi ça on verra on
verra pas qu'à partir de de la semaine
prochaine comment sans mal géré et
comment seront les gens si s'ils seront
toujours présents déjà d'une part et et
comment les ans ils partiront une
fermeture à 21h qui aura des
conséquences sur la gestion du personnel
puisqu'on va perdre quatre heures le
soir donc évidemment il y aura des gens
au chômage partiel à juziers dans ce
restaurant les clients viennent
d'habitude vers 20h30
cette fois pas le choix il faudra
adapter le service du soir on va
commencer à partir de 18 heures alors
est-ce qu'il va alors du monde ou pas je
suis pas convaincu mais voilà de 18
heures jusqu'à 20 heures on va dire
jusqu'à 20h pouvoir prendre des tables
dernière table à 20 heures le temps que
les gens puissent puissent manger et
tout et qu'en gros à 20h45
20h50 que le service soit terminée quoi
les propriétaires de l'atelier de gaëtan
ont perdu presque cent mille euros de
chiffre d'affaires cette année une perte
considérable pour une petite structure
comme celle ci ce qui correspond à nos
trois mois de fermeture plus une grosse
partie traiteur que nous avons aussi en
moins parce que
sur l'événementiel en ce moment nous
n'avons quasiment plus rien les
restaurants qui comptent moins de 50
salariés pourront compter sur le fonds
de solidarité à partir de 50 % de perte
de chiffre d'affaires l'aide pourra
aller jusqu'à dix mille euros
et pour continuer à parler de ce
couvre-feu nous sommes avec marie le bec
bonsoir bonsoir
la député de la 4e circonscription des
yvelines vous êtes également la première
vice-présidente du groupe la république
en marche à l'assemblée nationale merci
d'être avec nous en visio vingt mille
cas par jour que le président de la
république a dit vouloir réduire à trois
voire quatre mille cas dans les hôpitaux
franciliens ou précise aussi que le taux
d'occupation des lits de réanimation est
d'environ 45% mettre l'île de france et
huit métropoles de france en couvre feu
est ce que c'était la bonne décision à
prendre
c'est une décision déjà qu'on a pu
constater qu il soutenu par parler
français effectivement ce que l'on
cherche à faire depuis plusieurs
semaines c'est à tout prix éviter un
regroupement général de tout le pays qui
est à la fois très coûteux pour les gens
pour les entreprises et donc
effectivement le confinement permet de
limiter la propagation du virus dans les
lieux où on est le plus à même d'avoir
une certaine forme de relâchement et
donc effectivement il fallait cette
mesure pour endiguer l'épidémie est
effectivement passée de 20 mille à trois
mille à cinq mille cas de contamination
et de personnes auraient alors sont
notamment les rassemblements privé
familiaux que le président a dans le
viseur on a entendu dire dans
l'opposition mais aussi parmi certains
médecins de la communauté scientifique
que les principaux foyers de
contamination était plutôt à l'école à
l'université en entreprise
est ce que finalement emmanuel macron ne
s'attaque pas qu'à une toute petite
partie du problème
je crois que le temps n'est pas
tellement à la polémique ou à savoir si
le curseur est au bon endroit ce qui est
évident c'est que il y a des moments
on relâche son attention on est moins
attentive peut-être aux gestes barrières
et donc c'est dans ces moments là qu'il
faut être en capacité d'agir
au demeurant il faut reconnaître que les
universités ont aussi pris un certain
nombre de dispositions pour aborder
jouent le jeu moins importante dès 2012
notamment dans certaines universités et
que dans les écoles et moi je suis
notamment la situation en libye il ya eu
peu de fermeture de classe il a eu un
peu au début parce qu'il a fallu adapter
la méthode mais aujourd'hui on capacités
aussi de prendre en charge une classe
qui verrait à des cas de contamination
on sait comment comment s'adapter je
crois effectivement qu'il fallait
peut-être des mesures permettant de
contrer si physiquement à ces moments de
détente familiale ou entre amis alors
emmanuel macron a parlé aussi d'autres
sujets la règle des six notamment ne pas
être à table et ne pas se retrouver à
plus de 6 ça veut dire que ce couvre-feu
hocine sera efficace qu'avec d'autres
mesures la règle des six présidents en a
parlé il ya aussi peut-être la politique
des tests qu'il faut davantage renforcée
on parle on a parlé de tests anti
antigénique notamment qui pourrait être
renforcée des autotests alors tout à
fait c'est comme depuis le début de
cette épidémie c'est l'ensemble des
mesures
collectivement qui fonctionne c'est
effectivement le respect du port du
masque le respect des gestes barrières
comme chaque mois et c'est très
difficile d'interdire totalement d'avoir
une vie sociale d'où cette règle des six
qui permet de limiter en fait son cercle
social tout en conservant des liens
amicaux ou familiaux et puis
effectivement après je crois qu'il faut
saluer le fait qu'on a réussi à remonter
de très largement en capacité de tests
ou tests après 1,3 million de personnes
par par semaine mais ça mais aussi très
forte pression sur les laboratoires
d'analysés donc on cherche à développer
des alternatives des lieux alternatifs
pour se faire tester et des méthodes qui
permettent encore d'avoir un test plus
rapide aujourd'hui
vous n'êtes qu'à contacter il faut que
vous puissiez tout de suite savoir si
oui ou non vous êtes positif pour
pouvoir le plus en amont possible
reprendre une vie normale
davantage de mesures sur l'économie
aussi on a entendu dans le sujet
précédemment l'inquiétude des
restaurateurs le gouvernement s'est
d'ailleurs exprimé à ce sujet en
détaillant aussi notamment à plusieurs
politiques en matière d'économie est-ce
que c'est pas finalement aussi le
condamne à nouveau ce secteur de
l'économie qui avait un nouveau un petit
peu d'embellie
depuis quelques semaines on a depuis le
début de la crise cherchent à travailler
main dans la main avec les restaurateurs
avec les bars avec le secteur de
l'hôtellerie de l'événementiel
effectivement on sait où peut-être qu'il
trace de la manière la plus brutale
cette crise parce que ils ont un peu ce
qu'on pourrait appeler des stop and go
ils ont des fermetures et des et des
fois l'ouverture et on comprend la
pression qu'ils sont qui est mise sur ce
secteur d'activité mais vraiment on l'a
dit ne les rapports laissera pas tomber
on a encore une fois renforcé les prêts
des garanties d'état le fonds de
solidarité ont fait des mesures aussi
qui concerne le paiement des charges des
mesures qui sont en cours de réflexion
sur les loyers que si le président l'a
rappelé hier à l'occasion de son
intervention est donc vraiment on est là
pour répondre puis par ailleurs il ya on
voit ces lappartient pays marche de
l'iceberg
mais on n'oublie pas non plus les sous
traitants de sept de ces professions et
donc c'est aussi pour ça que on a ouvert
le fonds de solidarité aux eaux à la
monde on va dire de cette filière ou qui
commentent aussi dans les critères une
dernière chose marie le bec le couvre
feu sera effectif à partir du 17 octobre
minuit à zéro heure comme l'a dit le
président une durée de quatre semaines
minimum qu'il souhaite allonger à six
semaines jusqu'au 1er décembre
il va pour ce faire demandé l'accord au
parlement des députés des sénateurs
comment ça va se dérouler concrètement
et bien c'est comme les différents
textes de mesures d'urgence sanitaire
que nous prenons depuis le début il y a
la capacité pour le président
effectivement d'agir pendant quatre
semaines et puis ensuite il viendra
devant le parlement pour présenter les
mesures et leur donner une transcription
législative donc c'est vraiment le
processus très classique de la loi sera
débattu entre l'assemblée et le sénat
on espère dans un processus accéléré
comme nous le faisons depuis le début de
la crise mais ce qu'on remarque c'est
que la majorité comme les oppositions
sont quand même en soutien de ceux
plantes qui permet au gouvernement
d'agir rapidement et surtout d'endiguer
l'épidémie
oubliez que au delà bien sûr des
personnes sont malades c'est aussi la
pression sur notre système de santé et
nos soignants et c'est ça aussi qu'on
veut alléger
ah c'est mieux merci marie le bec
d'avoir réagi à ces annonces
présidentielles député de la 4e
circonscription des yvelines
[Musique]
et vous l'entendez il ya un instant
emmanuel macron va donc devoir demander
un vote aux parlementaires pour allonger
la durée de ce couvre-feu de quatre à
six semaines un débat aura bien lieu
prochainement nous confiant de la
sénatrice des yvelines martha de cidre
est même si elle ignore pour l'heure
quand la mesure sera à l'ordre du jour
je sais que nous allons débattre ça
c'est certain
puisque vous savez que depuis le début
de la crise le sénat est totalement
impliqué dans les décisions qui sont
prises et délibèrent délibère souvent
est d'ailleurs sur le volet du couvre
feu
c'est quand même une décision qui
n'était grave qui n'est pas neutre
le parlement doit pouvoir se prononcer
donc il faudra me reposer la question
dans quand nous aurons l'occasion d'en
débattre entre nous passer de quatre
semaines à six semaines c'est quelque
chose qui est là c'est sans doute
quelque chose de très prévisible oui
bien sûr enfin de tout à fait possible
mais les réactions à cette annonce parmi
les maires à présent sur twitter le
maire divers droite de saint germain en
laye arnaud péricard déplore le manque
de concertation avec les édiles pour ces
mesures qui impacte directement les
restaurateurs et les cafetiers
l'élu va militer la firme pour porter le
début du couvre feu de 21 heures à 22
heures
même constat du côté du maire de
versailles françois de mazières la ville
qui compte 250 restaurateurs écoutez le
interrogé par michael et demi d'euros on
comprend la nécessité de prendre les
mots courts par peut effectivement la
situation se tend peu quand annie terre
est ma priorité mais par contre passer
une heure dans des villes comme les
knicks ont des grandes villes les gens
rentrent relativement tard de leur
travail et qui on veut maintenant un
service qu'on a peur si on veut
maintenir un minimum d'activités
culturelles c'est vrai que 21 22 heures
était plus approprié que valent une va
être vraiment le couperet est là il est
impossible de ne rien faire croquant
culturel et pourquoi pour lé rappeur le
couvre-feu fixe à 21h que l'on déplore
également du côté des petits
communes notamment à magny les hameaux
le maire génération bertrand où ils ont
fait part de son incompréhension sur
twitter de cette démarche je cite
imposée brutalement une question aussi
trouvé un écho particulier depuis
quelques jours face à la recrudescence
de la crise sanitaire et après les
dernières annonces des manuels macron
quid des élections départementales et
régionales qui doivent se tenir en mars
prochain vont-elles pouvoir se tenir le
maire divers droite de poissy et vice
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines karl olive s'interroge
ironiquement d'un potentiel maintien du
scrutin alors que le salon de
l'agriculture est lui annulé fin février
pour le maire de la verrière nicolas
dainville qui est également conseiller
départemental du canton de trappes c'est
une réflexion qui doit se faire au jour
le jour concernant le couvre-feu l'élu
estime malgré tout que c'était une
mesure à prendre écoutez je pense que
c'est des mesures de bon sens c'est vrai
qu'on a une épidémie qui se propage qui
continue de faire beaucoup de victimes
notamment les personnes les plus
vulnérables
donc je pense que c'est des mesures qui
vont dans la bonne direction pour effet
de freiner la propagation du virus créé
vrai que la phrase qui revient souvent
c'est ce que je fais c'est que je ne
fais pas c'est que on ne fait pas du
tout comment les choses vont évoluer
la campagne est prévue pour mois de mars
là le couvre-feu cour dans les prochains
mois jusqu'au mois de décembre
voilà je ne peux vraiment rien vous dire
sur la suite il faut s'adapter au jour
le jour
on est en attente il faut se laisser la
liberté de choisir la meilleure
diffusion au meilleur moment et en tous
cas prévoir tous les cas de figure ça me
semble important de n'écarter aucune
hypothèse
voilà pour ces réactions politiques avec
l'annoncé du couvre feu c'est le monde
de la culture qui est aussi touché un
nouveau coup dur pour les salles de
spectacle et les cinémas qui vont devoir
fermer leurs portes à 21h les acteurs
culturels locaux vont tenter de
s'adapter justin brasier et patrick
jacques de dixmude salle de spectacle et
cinéma montils fermés ou bien s'adapter
les mesures gouvernementales annoncées
mercredi 14 octobre vont une nouvelle
fois impacté le monde culturel qui
commençait tout juste à reprendre
il entend se mobiliser pour maintenir
une offre est resté ouvert tout en
respectant le couvre-feu
évidemment il ya des spectacles qu'on va
pas pouvoir présenter mais on va
maintenir le théâtre ouvert et présenter
le maximum de spectacles dans les
contraintes qui nous sont imposées
aujourd'hui faire moins de séances
adapter les horaires des spectacles pour
respecter le couvre-feu de 21h les
salles auront 48 heures pour réagir
on est un peu pris de court on la prend
par exemple pour un concert qui a qui a
lieu samedi
c'est vrai qu'en terme de communication
va être un peu court pour dire aux
jambes séparées à 20h30 c'est à 18h
on risque de perdre on risque de perdre
beaucoup beaucoup de monde en route
je pense qu'on va décaler les sens
effectivement plus tôt c'est à dire on
va peut-être organiser les dernières
séances vers 18h30 19h de façon à ce
qu'à 21h les cinémas soit fermé une
discussion devrait avoir lieu demain
avec la ministre de la culture roselyne
bachelot une dérogation pourrait être
envisagée il est possible je dirais pas
probable que d'ici la fin de la journée
les théâtres puisse avoir une dérogation
pour terminer à 21h c'est à dire l'idée
c'est que les publics puis s'est
justifié avec leurs billets de leur
sortie du théâtre pour rentrer chez eux
un peu plus tard en juillet le ministère
de la culture a annoncé une baisse
moyenne du chiffre d'affaires et de 25 %
en 2020 par rapport à 2019 soit un
déficit de près de 22 milliards d'euros
à des conséquences aussi on en terminera
par la sur le monde du sport local et
club yvelinois vont devoir se
réorganiser pour les entraînements et
aussi les matches qui se jouent le soir
les détails et réactions avec ce sujet
de michael et le mindoro le monde du
sport et vie noailles bousculé par le
couvre-feu annoncé ce mercredi soir par
emmanuel macron certains matchs de
basketball au de handball programmé en
soirée sont d'ores et déjà annulés dans
le département au club de football de
poissy ne devrait pas y avoir de
conséquences sur les matches à domicile
de l'équipe senior et rencontres de
nationale 2 son programme est
généralement en fin de journée mais ce
sont les rencontres à l'extérieur en
bretagne qui interroge les dirigeants le
match se déroule à vis
heures donc à 20h45 ce qu'il faut une
heure de battement nous partons avec nos
équipes devront nous restait
effectivement sur la bretagne les frais
nécessaires et supplémentaires dont ce
sera difficile à supporter compte tenu
notre budget rester sur place de la
personne sur un hôtel effectivement ce
n'est pas envisageable pour nous
néanmoins si nous rentrons j'espère
vraiment nous aurons des dérogations au
delà des matches ce couvre feu va
entraîner une réorganisation des
horaires d'entraînement le soir pour
l'ensemble des clubs yvelinois c'est le
cas au rugby-club de versailles les
conséquences sont surtout
organisationnel avec l'avancée de tous
les deux tout les horaires
d'entraînement notamment pour les
seniors et les juniors qui s'entraînait
jusqu'à 21h30 20h30
évidemment avant c'est désormais à 19
heures pour terminer à 20h15 20h30 grand
maximum et pour que tout le monde soit
rentré chez soi à 21h la vie autour des
rencontres va également être perturbé
les après matchs si renommé dans le
monde du rugby et vont être impactés par
les nouvelles mesures annoncées
3e mi-temps sont remplacés par des
distributions sans rassemblement de
manière à éviter que le virus ne se
propage
après les matches et dans des conditions
dans des conditions festives qui sont du
coup à revoir mais encore une fois tant
qu'on peut jouer au rugby on fait avec
il faudra faire avec pendant au minimum
quatre semaines pour le sport yvelinois
voilà ce qu'on le on pouvez vous dire
sur cette actualité je vous le rappelle
mise en place du couvre feu en
ile-de-france et dans les yvelines à
partir de samedi minuit un couvre-feu
effective de 21h à 6h du matin et pour
une durée minimum de quatre semaines
d'ailleurs le 7-8 l'hebdo de demain
vendredi sera aussi est grandement
consacré à cette actualité
et nous souhaitions clôturer cette
édition avec une autre actualité
l'établissement français du sang fait
face à de grandes difficultés les
réserves sont très faibles
c'est pourquoi le fs lance un cri
d'alarmé on en parle avec le docteur
ahmed slimani bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
le responsable des prélèvements pour le
ffs ile-de-france le fs l'établissement
français du sang vous propose déjà de
regarder ce sujet tourné par astrid
bergère à vélizy-villacoublay crise
sanitaire canicule et départs en
vacances les causes sont multiples mais
le constat est bien là les réserves de
sang n'ont pas été aussi faible depuis
10 ans
l'établissement français du sang se
mobilisent et appelle à donner
immédiatement une collecte était
organisée à l'hôtel de ville de vélizy
mercredi 14 octobre et les donneurs ont
répondu présent j'ai effectué ma famille
ma maman qui est infirmière donc j'ai
rapidement les échos des besoins de sang
pourquoi je sais qu'en ce moment
particulier ils ont vraiment le besoin
c'est par un sms de le ffs que les
donneurs réguliers ont été prévenus de
l'urgence la proximité du lieu de
collecte encourage les donneurs à venir
je viens ici parce que j'habite à côté
se pratique c'est vrai que quand il faut
se déplacer c'est contraignant donc l'or
quand il n'y a pas besoin de se déplacer
trop loin c'est pas trop contraignantes
donc on a pas d' excuses et beaucoup de
demandes
voilà c'est un geste que qu'anodin en
plus j'ai travaillé pour la mairie donc
je suis à côté donc faire pratiquer pour
moi les collectes continue dans les
maisons du don de la ffs et dans les
collectes mobiles organisées
on l'entendait à mettre ce qu'il maniait
un geste qui est anodin pourtant la
situation aujourd'hui est alarmante
traditionnellement le les mois d'été
sont difficiles plus cette année avec
des les histoires de la crise sanitaire
qui ont fait qu'à la rentrée nous
n'avons pas pu avoir tous les donneurs
attendu 16 rajoute aussi sur le fait que
les entreprises collectées auparavant
n'ont pas pu nous accueillir pour des
raisons que vous connaissez télétravail
les établissements scolaires les
universités pareille ne venant pas pu
nous à nous accueillir
du fait de des vidéoconférences donc
nous a il nous rester uniquement le
grand public les communes comme le
reportage quand
devoir et malheureusement cela n'a pas
suffi à remonter les réserves qui ont
été très très basse au mois de septembre
et on n'avait pas connu cette crise
depuis dix ans qu'on en est aujourd'hui
concrètement au mois de septembre des
réserves très basse jamais vu depuis dix
ans est-ce que ça remonte légèrement
est-ce qu'on est toujours dans une
situation très alarmante
alors les réserves commencent à remonter
normalement je parle dans toute la
france et plus particulièrement la
région ile-de-france qui n'est pas
autosuffisante amenons près de vent que
60 % de nos besoins
malheureusement cette situation même si
elle se stabilise reste fragile
donc c'est pour ça on reste très
vigilant sur cette période
avec tout ce qu'on va avoir comme
problème avec cette ce couvre-feu la
crise sanitaire où on ne pourra pas
forcément pouvoir collecter toujours là
on veut justement vous allez vous
demander les dernières annonces
présidentielles celle de la mise en
place d'un couvre-feu même si les dons
du sang se déroulent en journée ce que
ça vous inquiète est ce que c'est de
mesure à vous inquiéter
vous savez l'établissement français du
sang s'est adapté depuis la crise
sanitaire depuis le mois de mars nous
n'avons pas arrêté de collecte et bien
entendu parce que nous avons une mission
envers nos malades avec l'histoire du
couvre-feu nous allons nous adapter soit
au niveau des horaires soit avec la
délivrance d'attestations pour tous les
donneurs qui vont se déplacer sur des
orages d'hier et de 20h ou 20h30
de toutes les manières nous allons
devoir nous adapter et nous n'arrêterons
pas de prélever même s'il ya cette
difficulté qui se rajoutent parce que
c'est un geste citoyen geste ô combien
important de ce que les besoins en
produits sanguins elle ne baisse pas un
malgré la crise anita il faudrait dix
mille dons par l'ours et ça pour assurer
les stocks en france il faut dix mille
dante par jour et en ile de france on a
besoin de 1700 dans et malheureusement
aujourd'hui on n'est pas capable d'avoir
ses 1700 dans on est obligé de faire
appel à la province et quand il ya des
difficultés en province bien sûr ça se
ressent sur l'île de france
concrètement c'est important aussi de le
rappeler ses dons de produits sanguins
ça permet de sauver des vies alors un
dans permet de sauver 3 vies
quand on fait un don de sang total
convient de le voir sur le reportage le
donneur peut donner des globules rouges
des plaquettes et du placement est ce
que vous avez aussi constatée depuis le
début de cette crise sanitaire et aussi
peut-être une inquiétude à venir dans
les lieux de collecte ou au contraire
les les yvelines on avait pu l'observer
pendant le confinement il y avait une
certaine mobilisation tout de même est
ce que ça s'est poursuivi alors
mobilisation a été très très accrue
pendant le confinement les gens ont pu
se déplacer
les mesures de sécurité sanitaires ont
été prises dès le début par
l'établissement français du sang à
savoir le nettoyage des mains avec une
solution hydroalcoolique à l'entrée le
port de masque obligatoire bon
aujourd'hui on est à deux mètres donc je
me suis permis d'enlever le masque mais
quand vous arrivez sur une collecte
toutes les mesures barrières sont prises
en compte le port de masques des
distanciation et depuis le mois de mars
nous avons tenu ce rythme sur la
sécurité du personnel des donneurs et
des bénévoles qui nous aident également
et aujourd'hui on n'a pas du tout
modifié notre façon de faire et on
restera sur ses mesures de sécurité
sanitaire donc nous on était dans un
lieu de collecte à vélizy-villacoublay
je crois que cette semaine aussi dans
les vignes avait mantes la ville qui
était prévu où peut-on donner il ya des
lieux mobile des lieux fixes aussi de
collex alors ça se basent nous réalisons
des collectes mobiles et nous avons
aussi des maisons du don nous en avons
12 en ile de france et la plus proche et
si c'est le chesnay un donc à côté de
l'hôpital
mignot les dons du sang c'est très
simple aujourd'hui on est sur un système
de rendez vous pourquoi système de
rendez-vous ça permet d'éviter la
fluence qui dit affluence des risques
sanitaires dits tristes de 2,2
d'attroupement les rendez vous on peut
aller sur le site fait face au poids net
où on peut trouver les endroits voilà
les endroits où on peut donner ou une
application sur marque smart phones et
là on qu'on va retrouver l'endroit le
plus proche
collectes mobiles aux maisons du temps
et on peut à ce moment-là prendra rendez
vous le leur qui nous convient et allait
donner notre sang une question qui peut
donner son sang alors que tu vas avoir
plus de 18 ans donc c'est de 18 à 70 ans
révolus fait en bonne santé
il ne faut pas venir à jeun surtout il
faut déjeuner ou prendre son petit
déjeuner quand on vient donner son sang
il faut bien s'hydrater
après quand je dis il faut être en bonne
santé
les critères sont variables donc vous
pouvez aller sur l'application de la ffs
où vous avez l'éligibilité pour pouvoir
savoir s'il pouvait donner votre sang ou
pas s'il ya une question vous avez
numéro de téléphone où on pouvait
appeler pour avoir des renseignements
il inclut nous reste une minute si vous
avez un message à faire passer aux
yvelinois peut-être qu'il serait encore
réfractaires à venir donner leur sang
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de leur
dire soyez solidaires
venez sauver des vies on peut sauver 3
vies en une heure de temps et je tiens à
remercier tous les donneurs et
spécifiquement aujourd'hui on est dans
les yvelines les yvelinois pour leur
mobilisation toute l'année et je dis
données et redonner et merci aussi à
tous les bénévoles qui se mobilisent
avec nous pour sauver des vies merci à
vous merci
slimani médecin responsable des
prélèvements à l'établissement français
du sang d'ile-de-france toutes les
informations sur le site internet qui
s'est affichée tout au long de cet
entretien à voilà c'est la fin de cette
édition spéciale merci de votre fidélité
une édition à retrouver en replay sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile très belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]